depuis plus de 150 millions d'années les
peurs du peuple nos océans
pourtant aujourd'hui on estime que la
quasi totalité des espèces est menacée
ou grandement menacée bonjour à tous
celles et à aujourd'hui je vous emmène
dans un centre de soins pour les tortues
pour comprendre les menaces qui pèsent
sur elle et pourquoi ils sont le témoin
direct de la pollution plastique dans
les océans c'est par ici
[Musique]
nous sommes sept med qui est le centre
d'étude et de sauvegarde des tortues
marines de méditerranée
on va pouvoir découvrir comment elles
sont soignées mais aussi comment elles
vont être relâchés c'est parti
quant à elles sont prises dans les
filets de pêche et les pêcheurs qui vous
appelle du coup les pêcheurs qui nous
appellent voilà on
en collaboration avec eux ils savent
très bien que cet espace andré
disparition même si physiquement elles
ont l'air d'aller bien
on les prend pas ce qu'on sait jamais
avoir du plastique en l ou alors un
hameçon voilà on courait que tu perds
toutes les tortues marines
qui a quoi comme espèce nouveau centre
de soins en quinze ans ça fait 15 ans
qu'on se souhaite existe on a eu un peu
près
cinq cent tortues dont majoritairement
que des tortues caouannes on a eu de
très très peu de tortues vertes
c'est très répandu la tortue caouanne
mais c'est la plus répandue en
méditerranée dans le monde
déjà pour reconnaître une tortue
caouanne c'est
les écailles frontale
gala dans la catégorie comptable la
tortue verte par exemple l'un d'eux
auquel on voit très bien sur ce ticket
en a quatre plus nous voilà ensuite
qu'une tortue caouanne quand elle est
juline on peut remarquer parce que c'est
la seule qui a des petits pics sur les
écailles aux dorsales est reparti avec
le crabe avec le temps qui se lisent
voilà plus la carapace est grosse plus à
solis une tortue caouanne ça peut faire
jeu
81 kg et 1 m me voilà donc c'est la
troisième tortues marines la plus grosse
la première étant la tortue luth plus
clair jusqu'à deux mètres 900 kg il ya
sept espèces de tortues marines dans le
monde alors il ya la tortue fabriquer
cette espèce a disparu à cause du
braconnage
la séquence est la nouvelle carapace
voilà pourquoi
tu as donc laquelle qu'on trouve là
qu'en australie on à la tortue
kawano pour trouver en méditerranée la
tortue verts ils se retrouvent en
méditerranée tortue luth qu'on trouve en
méditerranée aussi on à la tortue
olivâtre d'ailleurs elle a cinq
chapelles oliva parce que sa carapace et
couleur olive - celle-là oui c'est ça et
on à la tortue kemp est le week-end il
me semble qu'elle ne pond coup golfe du
mexique
là on vient d'aller chercher du poisson
deux types de poissons différents pour
aller nourrir du coup les tortueux qui
sont pas dans cette pièce
s'il vient de prendre un art ans déjà
ouais donc là c'est pour totti ces cinq
repas par jour et le 1er mai à 9 heures
sa partie préférant va céder au coupé en
deux morceaux ça fait un peu court pour
est proportionnellement à nous ce qu'on
me suis engagé un steak de la taille de
notre tête
cinq fois on peut essayer de lui mettre
de l'accrocher dans la petite tige en
faire si tu veux essayer de tout donner
elle peut tenir pendant quatre mois
je ne sais pas si je tiens hongrie 4
mois sans manger
[Musique]
en fait c'est un enfant de 9 ans qui est
parti seul en guyane sa grand-mère et le
dernier jour avant de partir
un chien qui mangeaient des tortues bon
il a essayé de récupérer en oeuvre pour
un serre-tête le sauver voilà sauvetage
l'a mis dans son sac à dos et puis la
laisser là il a pris l'avion et rentrer
en france
neuf jours plus tard la tortue sorti de
l'oeuf il ramène à une clinique
vétérinaire
le vétérinaire anime ici une tortue de
mer moi je peux rien faire c'est une
espèce menacée en tant que centre de
soins notre rôle c'est de la maintenir
en vie de la ferme grossir un petit peu
et dans quelques semaines
or le moine agents de l'état en meneur
en guise ça c'est la carte spécifique de
totti le nombre de repas qu'elle francs
par jour on voit que ça va jusqu'à cinq
repas par jour qu'elle fera un gramme et
donc c'est une bonne croissance cwy
c'est normal c'est bien c'est régulier
en tout cas
mais là on va regarder un peu la tortue
et ma voile a été capturé à quelque
temps dans un chalutier
du coup elle a été un peu brûlé sur
certains endroits avec le filet voile à
la friction du filet et on va juste
contrôler ces petites blessures qui ont
ainsi qu'à prisé depuis ont coincé
vaudois juste derrière le vent les
cailles nucale et aux écailles derrière
les écailles caudal voilà il y avait
quelques petites blessures à cet endroit
il faut quand même toujours faire
attention au bec qui peut vendre et
c'est assez tranchants enlevé quelques
charmantes bêtes genève
n ont pas le même processus de
cicatrisation fait nous ça cicatrise est
quand même beaucoup plus vite que nous
et surtout avec peu de risques
d'infection
été impressionnant quand ils vous
experts dorothy njeuma vent mais pas des
masses qui sont des trous
c'est superficiel parfois on a carrément
des tortues à qui manque
un grand morceau de carapace ou une
nageoire najwa donc là c'est le des
blessures beaucoup plus importante
on n'a pas l'impression mais c'est quand
même les animaux sauvages dont qu'ils
ont un stress au niveau de chaque
manipulation on essaie d'en faire le
moins possible moi juste la pesée elle a
perdu 1 kg mais elle va aller reprendre
très rapidement
cet été les principaux dangers pour une
sortie succès adultes ça peut être les
hélices des bateaux qui peuvent leur
couper la carapace c'est la pollution
marine et les fidèles ont un producteur
naturel
ouais quand elles arrivent à l'âge
adulte présente très peu de prédateurs
en méditerranée par exemple il ya que le
requin blanc toutes les tortues sont
voués à être relâché c'est aussi pour ça
que le centre
est ce qu'il ya des exceptions il ya
quelques stations une donc
particulièrement qu'ils aient haussé
corium donc je voulais présenter mais
juste à côté du coût exact
à la série ces tortues là sa carapace a
été coupée en deux par une hélice de
bateau
mais en fait elle avait la tête en bas
voilà et la kératine en fait là qu'alain
passer les fêtes kératine dans la
matière de nos cheveux nous on pense à
cicatriser rapidement c'est comme nos
cicatrices annoncé
moins complet donc sa carapace est
écoulé japon qu'ils ont mis deux plombs
derrière la carapace de la tortue
combines pour la stabiliser pour que
puisse nager ce nouveau le problème
c'est que
5 les rapaces elle m'a donc aidé à quai
qui sont donc les plombs peuvent
s'ennuie donc cette tortue là ne peut
pas être lâché en mer parce que si on
l'a relâché carton l'âge elle est
condamnée à rester la tête en bas et pas
pouvoir se nourrir
la chine a condamné en fait voilà
au delà des soins prodigués aux tortues
lui aussi un véritable travail
scientifique est effectuée au 7 m du
coup on va partir à la rencontre de
delphine d'envoi yannick et biologiste
au cns
alors du coup des finances paul consiste
ton travail ici au centre de soins on va
récupérer un maximum d'informations
toujours dans un but de de conservation
de protection de l'espèce ces tortues
l'europe a choisi de les utiliser comme
indicateur de déchets en mer ce qu'elle
a géré ce qu'on trouve dans leur traque
usagers stif ça serait représentatif de
ski en l'air en fait et donc nous on
travaille là dessus
d'où viennent mais tous ces échantillons
c'est des échantillons qui ont été
prélevés lors des autopsies donc sur des
animaux morts mais aussi sur des animaux
vivants avec l'analyse de leur sel de
leurs leur fait cette crotte les filles
c'est quand même problématique
mais les fils tu vas j'aurais eu
tendance à croire que ce n'était pas
forcément une menace parce que tu te dis
que c'est tellement petit que c'est ce
qui est bien en fait les cordes les fils
sa tendance à faire des occlusions
intestinales en fait
l'intestin l'as ramassés autour de ce
fil et que rien ne passe et c'est là où
s'arrête la mort de l'animal d'accord
alors qu'est ce que tu vas nous montrer
là c'est les résultats ont fait des
autopsies qui ont été faites en 2017 et
2018 et dans quatre pays
on a la france l'espagne l'italie et la
grèce et en rouge
vous avez le taux de gestion pour le cas
de la france sur les 38 individus
autopsiés 80% d'entre eux avaient des
déchets plastiques dans le système
digestif et d'eau pour l'espagne du coup
l'espagne alors il ya l'échantillonnage
est plus plus petits uniquement 15
individus qui ont été autopsiées mais
tous avaient avait été déchue dans le
système digestif
l'une des principales menaces qui pèsent
sur les tortues marines et la pollution
au plastique
ici nous sommes à palavas les flots pour
partir à la rencontre de tier 2 sagas
l'eau ce qui va nous expliquer que la
méditerranée n'échappe pas du tout à ce
fléau
l'europe c'est le deuxième plus gros
pollueur de plastique après la chine
avec 27 millions de tonnes de plastique
par an dont seulement un tiers est
recyclé donc aujourd'hui concrètement
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à notre
échelle alors les gens te propose de
vous lancer un défi à dire te lancer
mais me lancer nous lance un défi
on va essayer pendant 10 minutes de
ramasser un maximum de déchets pour voir
ce que ça peut donner
j'ai lancé mon chrono donc aller les
sticks d'incendié j'ai pas de gants mais
j'aurais dû ramasser ce déchet l'acquis
et d'autre un dg que l'on trouve
énormément une des couches c'est une
paille alentours de sucettes
voilà un mégot qui tape de plusieurs
années
on a fait dix minutes 10 minutes et
voilà déjà les déchets dans une classe
jusqu'à déjà été nettoyé je pensais
sincèrement pas trouver autant de
déchets et surtout des déchets aussi
divers et variés on en parlait justement
tout à l'heure avec delphine les petits
filets en fait de plastique comme ça
pour les animaux et même pas que les
tortues c'est c'est très dangereux
alors là je pense qu'on est sur un petit
emballage de sandwichs pour les couples
il ya beaucoup de petites serviettes en
papier il ya aussi beaucoup d'emballages
de glace ou de gâteaux pas mal de
gobelets plastiques de la lui est certes
oui ça c'est je pense et l emballage
d'un sandwich fait maison
malheureusement on va pouvoir tout
mettre dans la poubelle qui est juste là
derrière puisque ces déchets ont été
ramassés à proximité d'une poubelle mais
je note quand même que les gens nous
disaient que c'était vachement bien et
ce qui nous ont vus ramasser mais nous
non pas du tout aidé les océans sont en
veille de pollution notamment dans cinq
zones
les déchets sont concentrés dans ce
qu'on appelle des gir océanique qui sont
des tourbillons géant qui concentre le
plastique au même endroit on estime que
la plus importante de ces zones et dans
le pacifique nord pourtant il se
pourrait que la méditerranée soit
beaucoup plus concentrés en plastique
que cette zone après avoir été en soins
les tortues sont amenés ici on est à la
grande motte s'ajuste à quelques
kilomètres du centre de soins c'est un
centre de réhabilitation où elles sont
en semi liberté avant d'être
complètement relâché
quelques semaines et après c'est la
liberté
quel est le but exactement de septembre
mais justement pour cet ordre qui ont
passé du temps d'un vin captivité un
soin le but c'est de les réhabiliter au
milieu naturel à faire en sorte que leur
trouve un peu tout ou ses instincts
naturels qu'elle sache à nouveau manger
du vivant et surtout nager retrouvez la
musculature qu'elle avait avant de
d'arriver au centre
alors combien de temps en moyenne on
reste ici quand on est une tortue elles
vont rester en moyenne deux semaines et
elles vont regagner la mer mais ça peut
être aussi un endroit intéressant pour
des tortues qui ont été hospitalisés qui
on a imputé une nageoire par exemple et
ça va être une étape qui va leur
permettre de se réadapter à leur
handicap ou est ce qui tue
c'est un endroit qui est plus proche de
la mer et c'est là où on a le plus de
chance d'observer ces tortues puisque le
bon essayer quand même toujours leur
instinct les pousse à essayer de rejouer
s'intéressant à cet animal on va aussi
s'intéresser el général à la mer aux
océans et on va pouvoir peut-être faire
en sorte que les gens prennent
conscience que c'est quelque chose de
vivant et de fragile la torture ça peut
être en symbole de mon élection en
négociant et ça va permettre à tout un
chacun des deux bords a envie de
protéger cette hausse hier on attend des
vents beaucoup de choses mission sur une
plastique etc
mais finalement change pas nos habitudes
ça c'est le plus long
c'est pas facile de pâques
changer ses habitudes de se dire qu'au
final tout seul
un impact sur la planète quant à tous la
possibilité de
quelque chose
[Musique]
en
oh